este hombre acaba de acertar El premio
mayor eufórico el dueño del equipo de
baloncesto San Antonio ha ganado la
lotería más esperada del año en Estados
Unidos y el premio gordo es él Víctor
wenvaniama de 19 años el francés es el
basquetbolista más prometedor del
momento en el corazón de la noche de
París descubrió en directo su probable
destino visiblemente encantado tanto
como los fanáticos de los Sports en
Texas
esta temporada ha sido muy dolorosa pero
todo ha valido la pena Eso es todo vamos
a tener a buen banyama desde que
escuchamos un nombre estuvimos seguros
de que los títulos pronto volverán a San
Antonio San Antonio es la ciudad que vio
brillar a otra leyenda del baloncesto
francés Tony Parker ganador de cuatro
títulos de la NBA de este niño Víctor
huambaniamas se ha proyectado como un
grande anunciado como una perla rara su
talento se eleva hoy a dos metros 21
centímetros de altura con su Club
cerca de París Wendy como se le conoce
atrae a las estrellas kilian mbappé Omar
sí la locura de guambañama está lista
para la exportación
miedos con 21 tiene 19 años tiene ese
talento en sus manos tiene destreza a un
tiro sedoso y un coeficiente intelectual
de baloncesto fenomenal y el deseo de
brillar y hacer historia tiene el
paquete completo el próximo 22 de junio
en el Draft de la NBA conocerá
oficialmente Su futuro le toca él
escribir su historia en la liga de
baloncesto más competitiva del mundo